waouh ok là c'est vrai là ça commence à
être vraiment là on commence à
s'approcher du pont la finition final
c'est le marquage d'un qu'on est rendus
là c'est que on est tout près elle est
ce que ça sera le plus gros projet de
votre vie professionnelle oui c'est ici
de cet empereur qui est tiré de la
battre etes-vous fier je pense que tu
manques et travailler sur des projets
sont extrêmement fiers
c'est vraiment un chef-d'oeuvre ses yeux
c'est un projet de classe mondiale avant
notre raison des pieds à tout le monde
qu'ils travaillaient sur vous ça fait
combien de temps vous êtes là tu à temps
plein à temps plein ça fait à peu près 7
1 et puis même deux enfants là pour une
autre à des études de préfaisabilité on
la choisira alès on allait faire un
temps où un tunnel à sa part d'au moins
neuf ans de ma vie et je suis content
qu'on ait eu un bon fond est-ce qu'on
devient dans une classe mondiale c'est
un pont qui sera peut-être gardé par
d'autres pour le délai que sap réussi à
7,1 en appel un choc et c'est un projet
exemplaire là c'est sûr c'est un projet
qui tient beaucoup de l'attention
internationale
la pommade aux états unis et en europe
alors c'est vraiment des projets de
cette nature là on encore
tous les jours les délais ça a été court
on le sait vous avez dépassé d'ailleurs
le l'entrepreneur a dépassé la date
limite est ce que c'était inévitable de
votre esprit que des délais ben on
savait dès le départ que c'est un
échéancier agressif mais contenue
s'aguerrir compte tenu de l'état du pont
actuel on ne peut pas beaucoup de choix
le faut vraiment essayer de le mettre de
nouveau en service le plus rapidement
possible on le fait pour combien de
temps parce que l'autre à peine mon âge
celui qui et puis bon je peux aussi
vieux que cela je sais qu'un ancien 15
56 lui il va durer beaucoup plus
longtemps
c'est un pauvre con a conçu pour 125 ans
pour toutes les pièces non remplacés à
la libérer mais les pièces non
remplaçable
c'est tous les éléments importants de la
structure évidemment on est un petit peu
moins bon au canada s'est fait trop 75 à
125 ans est pas mal dans le top en
amérique du nord il n'ya pas encore
confédération puisse entamer 125 ans on
s'est dit mais quand on peut répéter le
même sur le port d'origine
avons nous vraiment tout mettre en
oeuvre pour essayer d atteindre une
grande île habitée pour grands
on voit que du pavage devant nous ça
continue quoi jusqu'à la dernière minute
ça va être jusqu'à la dernière minute
pour la dernière étape où il l'a marqué
qu'est-ce qui a été le plus difficile
dans tout ce projet là pour vous le
meilleur
ben il est content il est le plus de 6,6
la masse et l'échéancier c'est un projet
auquel c'est un grand projet là c'est un
projet en conception construction parce
qu'au début
bien qu'on donne le contrôle de design
pour compléter les cinq jeunes doivent
compléter le design alors même temps qui
complète le design certaines parties du
pont qui avait construit par exemple les
filons principal c'est ça qui est encore
en train de finaliser le design la
superstructure mais déjà foulé qui
maintenait qu remplace alors c'est
vraiment à ce krach du début à la fin
pièces de lego géant au complexe il vous
l'avez dit c'est important quand on a
construit des ponts dans l'histoire de
l'humanité on additionne les morts
depuis que les gens meurent à new york
c'était comme ça comme ça ici il n'y a
pas eu au paiement s'il ya eu un
accident monde
voyons des actes ans est meilleur qu
aucun des six nations sur l'a7 en
ce qui était ce qu'est ce qui est assez
rare pour un projet de cette envergure
j'imagine vous êtes fiers de travailler
sur ce projet là on est bien on ne
travaillait pas on est tous très
fatigués mais on a refusé à livrer puis
on voit la fin vous faisiez quoi vous
depuis combien de temps vous êtes reçu
trois manches contre ahmad menu des
manoeuvres
combien de gens ont travaillé à ce fonds
maintient dans la pointe avec 1006 1
ouvriers sur le site tâche de la tuer ou
ans un ingénieur et personne dans les
bureaux pour supporter des équipes qui
en plus de cette coupe du monde qui
seront dans les usines de fabrication
aussi qu'ils ont participé la
fabrication des éléments et des éléments
qui ont été fabriqués à saint-eugène
près de drummondville environ 50
kilomètres entre québec et aussi vous
fabriquer beaucoup de pièges des dépôts
de questions de renseignement de
questions côté ça bute est livré au site
globalement des pièces importantes qui
sont arrivées jusqu'à l'espagne en
arrivant au port de montréal a lancé une
fabrication à travers le monde on a eu
une bonne partie au québec
et puis on ne mobilise pas la seule
façon de résister projet là dans le camp
qui termine cette musique soul à la
préfabrication l'orne et aux choeurs
loreto sur le port à aubin alors ces
scellés au vin que vous essayez années
c'est tout ça qui retient le poids du
ces tabliers c'est pas pour que les gens
comme ses propres locaux
c'est ce qui impose à l'intérieur de ce
que les gaines extérieur que vous voyez
il ya un nombre important de profonds en
acier à haute résistance et c'est tous
ceux qui supportent le pont imaginons
qu'un tremblement de terre où il ya
quelque chose ça résiste très bien ça
oui en effet le pont il est très
flexible alors plutôt que d'absorber
beaucoup de force il va se déplacer et
conçu vraiment % et + autres ont
vraiment peur qu'on peut s'attendre ici
en 2001 ça c'est vraiment très
impressionnant
on est ici les traits vont passer ici
les trains vont passer en pleine santé
s'ils vont porter sur ce qu'on appelle
la porte à roullens 3 supérieur et
et on voit la elvis les haubans le
pilote principal aussi vous et éclairé
de nous jusqu'au haut alors ça va être
vraiment un ford on
la paix cyclables on peut la voir à peu
près tout à fait la presse il vient des
mesures 3.5 mètres de largeur on peut la
voir on peut se rapprocher comme si on a
un but fantastique sur teixeira
ordinaire l'a vu contre exceptionnel une
promène bellevue la gym et arrivent en
vélo ici ils vont avoir une main
courante aussi qui va être éliminé y
voit un éclaireur dans la main courante
alors c'est vraiment une vue fantastique
sur le central on a vraiment un beau
pour centre-ville cmn porte d'entrée à
leur sort était très important
un monsieur mayotte bien sûr qu'il ya
des problèmes et c'est là mais au nom de
tous ceux qui nous écoutent des
spectateurs je vous dis merci parce que
les gens sont fiers de ce travail la
fierté d'un ouvrage bief tout le monde
et puis contre moi je suis ingénieur en
bon futur de pouvoir par un projet de
grande valeur dans ma cour arrière
quatre mandats c'est vraiment
fantastique
je pense que tout le monde a un feeling
à tout le monde a travaillé dessus avec
lyon son club de prendre
on a hâte de passer dessus merci
beaucoup merci merci à toi